a eric se le pidió determinar si la
función de x igual a x cuadrada menos 1
esto el llamado a las dos tercios tienen
un máximo relativo está su respuesta y
bueno aquí tenemos los pasos que siguió
y me preguntan es correcto el trabajo de
eric si no es así dónde está su error
así que pausa el vídeo y ps puedes
encontrar la respuesta sobre el trabajo
de eric saber si es correcto y si no lo
es en dónde está el error muy bien vamos
a trabajarlo juntos él dice que esta es
la derivada de esta función así que
vamos a calcular la nosotros y me
quedaría ya que tengo espacio lo voy a
poner aquí efe prima de x ok y observa
es simplemente aplicar la regla de la
cadena
tengo la derivada del exterior con
respecto al interior
entonces me quedarían
dos tercios dos tercios que multiplican
al interior x cuadrada menos uno esto
elevado a la dos tercios menos uno bueno
dos tercios menos uno es menos un tercio
menos un tercio ok y esto a su vez que
multiplican a la derivada de lo de
adentro con respecto a equis y bueno la
derivada de x cuadrada menos 1 es
simplemente 2x de lujo y ahora se
multiplicó 2x por 2 bueno esto es lo
mismo que 4x ok vamos bien con la parte
de arriba y en el denominador observa me
queda este 3 este 3 que tengo aquí ok y
como tengo x cuadrada menos 1 elevado a
la menos un tercio bueno esto es lo
mismo que x cuadrada menos 1 esto
elevado a la un tercio positivo si lo
ponemos en el denominador y esto es
exactamente lo mismo que m
tomar la raíz cúbica de x cuadrada menos
x cuadrada menos 1 y si observas es
justo lo que tengo aquí así que el paso
1 está bien tenemos aquí nuestra
derivada y ahora vamos al paso número 2
en el paso 2 me dice que el punto
crítico ocurre en x igual a 0
veamos los puntos críticos los
encontramos cuando la primera derivada
es igual a cero o es indefinida si f
prima de x es igual a cero puedes ver
que en efecto x igual a cero aze efe
prima de x igual a cero observa
efe prima evaluada en cero va a ser
igual y bueno 4 x 0 eso es simplemente
cero en la parte de abajo me quedaría 3
que multiplica a la raíz cúbica ok de 0
- 1 lo cual es menos 1 así que en efecto
esto es 0 y por lo tanto un punto
crítico ocurre en x igual a cero eso es
muy cierto
pero ojo la pregunta sería es este el
único punto crítico y bueno hay que
recordar que los puntos críticos los
encontramos cuando la primera derivada
es igual a cero o es indefinida y aquí
tenemos el único lugar donde nuestra
función derivada es igual a cero pero
tal vez podamos encontrar algunos
valores donde esta función derivada sea
indefinida qué pasaría si hacemos el
denominador de nuestra derivada igual a
cero bueno observa si x cuadrada menos 1
esto de aquí es 0 entonces todo el
denominador me quedaría igual a cero
cuando x cuadrada menos 1 es igual a 0 x
toma el valor de más menos 1 estás de
acuerdo y en este caso mi primera
derivada es indefinida así que lo voy a
notar si x es igual a 1 oa menos 1 mi
primera derivada es
indefinida y es por esta razón que no me
estoy sintiendo del todo bien sobre el
paso número 2 de hecho voy a ponerle
signos de interrogación porque creo que
por aquí está el error
y tal vez tú estés tentado a decidir
bueno es que no encontró los demás se le
olvidó pero x igual a 0 es el máximo
relativo que él estaba buscando y por lo
tanto lo perdonamos pero como ya
hablamos en algunos vídeos para usar la
prueba de la primera derivada y
encontrar los máximos y los mínimos de
una función necesitas probar qué es lo
que sucede alrededor de los puntos
críticos y ver si cambian o no cambia de
signo la primera derivada al hacer la
prueba debes de tener cuidado de no
pasar por otro punto crítico porque un
punto crítico puede ser un lugar donde
cambios de dirección y vamos a ver qué
es lo que hace en el paso 3
-viernes efecto en el paso 3 está
intentando probar con valores a los
lados del punto crítico que encontró el
que es igual a 0 pero el problema es que
hace la prueba pasando los otros puntos
críticos x igual a menos 3 es más allá
del valor de menos 1 que era nuestro
otro punto crítico que encontramos y x
igual a 3
punto más allá de nuestro último punto
crítico x igual a 1 lo que realmente él
debió de haber hecho es ver qué sucedía
entre x igual a menos 0.5 y x igual a
0.5 y tal vez por ahí intentar concluir
es más déjame hacer una tabla para que
veas a lo que me refiero lo que tal vez
tuvo que hacer
eric era lo siguiente voy a hacer una
tabla aquí porque es una tabla muy
grande así que por aquí me voy a tomar
algunos valores de x y hay que ver qué
es lo que pasa con la primera derivada
ok y bueno él tuvo que tomar algunos
valores se me ocurre el valor de menos 2
que están antes de menos 1 ver qué es lo
que pasa en menos 1 que ya sabemos que
la primera derivada es indefinida ver
qué es lo que pasaba con menos 0.5 ok
menos un medio después ver qué es lo que
pasaba en cero después ver qué es lo que
pasaba con 0.5 ojo observa que no
estamos pasando nos del otro punto
crítico
punto crítico es que es lo que pasa en
uno y por último ver qué es lo que
pasaba en x igual a 2 después del último
punto crítico ok esta era la tabla que
él tenía que hacer recuerda esto porque
sabemos que x igual a 0 es un punto
crítico ok
fue lo que él encontró haciendo la
primera derivada igual a 0 pero también
sabemos que es igual a menos 1 es un
punto crítico porque nuestra función
derivada se hace indefinida es un
candidato extremo y lo mismo pasa con x
igual a 1 es un candidato extremo es un
punto crítico porque su primera derivada
es indefinida así que hay que ver en qué
situaciones hay un cambio de signo en la
primera derivada y para eso evaluamos
puntos en los intervalos entre los
puntos críticos así que ya estamos
seguros el paso incorrecto es el paso
número dos ya que no identificó- todos
los puntos críticos
es la solución nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo